Al Gore: Thank you very much.
Whitney Pennington Rodgers: Hi, Al.
Thank you so much for being here.
Just as I mentioned,
you gave a rousing talk
at Climate Countdown last fall
about all of the things that we need to do
to transform climate change
and to turn things around here.
What would you say is the state of play
with climate action now, six months later?
AG: Well, thanks in part
to many of the people
that are part of the TED community,
we've seen tremendous progress
in the development of affordable,
cheap, solar electricity,
wind electricity,
electric vehicles, batteries,
regenerative agriculture,
green hydrogen is coming along,
sustainable forestry.
But unfortunately,
the crisis is getting much worse,
much faster than predicted.
And it is getting worse at a rate faster
than the rate at which
we're deploying these solutions.
We have everything we need,
save sufficient political will.
It's been that way for a while.
And just since the Glasgow conference,
we have seen a lot of backsliding
and we've seen financial institutions,
banks and large investors,
pumping more and more and more money
into more and more fossil fuels.
It is quite literally insane.
Today, we will put
another 162 million tonnes
into the thin shell of atmosphere
surrounding the planet.
And the accumulated amount
now traps as much extra heat
as would be released by 600,000
Hiroshima-class atomic bombs
exploding every 24 hours.
Just, you know, 95 miles northeast of here
in Lytton, British Columbia,
it reached 121.3 degrees
less than a year ago.
49.6 Celsius.
More than 80 all-time
high temperature records
were broken here in British Columbia
just in less than a year ago.
One day later, by the way,
the entire town burned up.
Yesterday, massive death
in the Philippines
from another superstorm
fueled by the climate crisis.
Chile just yesterday
declared a drought emergency.
But we are seeing the development
of the solutions.
Unfortunately, the financial interest,
the fossil fuel companies,
have captured the policy-making
process in key countries
and have intentionally zombified
as many people as they can
around the world
with false messaging
that they knew was false.
They knew it,
it's been proven to a fare-thee-well.
And as a consequence,
our political decision-making
process in key countries
is locked, paralyzed.
So the political will necessary
to break through this
has to be expressed
in a much more effective way.
We are nearing a political event horizon.
And in the United States,
JP Morgan Chase, Citi, Wells Fargo ...
Others, Bank of America,
Royal Bank of Canada here ...
Several banks in Canada
joined the Net-Zero Banking Alliance,
and then last year they doubled
the amount of money
pumped into the tar sands,
which is the dirtiest form
of fossil fuels.
You know, when junkies
can't use the veins
in their arms and legs anymore,
they shoot between their toes.
That's what the tar sands is like.
So I want to say
that this is a moment
when we have to rise to this occasion.
Abraham Lincoln said the occasion
is piled with difficulty,
piled high with difficulty,
and we have to rise with the occasion.
As our case is new,
we must think anew and act anew.
We have to find ways
to solve the democracy crisis
in order to solve the climate crisis.
(Applause)
WPR: Well, you know,
I think with the war in Ukraine,
we're now seeing the question of energy
security being brought center-stage.
And I'm curious what you think
that will do in terms of accelerating
or decelerating the energy transition?
AG: Yeah, well, this should be
a moment of global epiphany.
This is a fossil fuel war,
as many have said.
And the timidity of some
European countries, understandably,
because they are so dependent
on Russian gas and oil,
is another consequence of our dependence.
And then we see this horrible scene
where the United States
goes begging other petrostates,
like Saudi Arabia and Venezuela and Iran,
to pump up more and more fossil fuels.
We should see this as a threat
to national security and global security.
It is a threat
to disadvantaged communities.
I mean, the coal pollution
from burning fossil fuels
kills nine million people every year.
A large multiple of the number
of people killed by COVID
are killed annually
by the particulate pollution
that comes from fossil fuels.
We can save money,
we can fight inflation, by the way.
The sustainability revolution,
including renewable energy,
is massively deflationary.
The cost continues to go down.
There are multiple reasons
why we should see this
as a moment of decision
to make a big change
and get off of fossil fuels.
We can't keep pumping more and more money
in pursuit of short term profit
in activities that are destroying
the future of humanity.
This is not a time for moral cowardice.
This is not a time for surrender
and reckless indifference
to the fate of humanity.
WPR: I think in thinking
about this being a time for change,
the IPCC recently put out a report
where they said that if we do want
to come around the bend,
that we have until 2025
to see CO2 levels peak.
I mean, that's just three years from now.
How realistic do you think that actually?
AG: Well, actually, what they said,
it needs to peak between 2020
and no later than 2025, yes.
First, let me share some good news
from that dire IPCC report.
They also said if we reach
net-zero, true net-zero,
then the temperatures on our planet
will stop going up
with a lag of as little as
three to five years.
And if we stay at net-zero,
half of the human-caused CO2
in the atmosphere
will fall out of the atmosphere
in as little as 25 to 30 years.
We have the technologies,
we have the solutions,
we have the ability to stop
this progressive destruction
of the future of humanity
and start the long healing process.
But we have to break through the capture
of our political systems.
They say boycotts don't work.
Should we boycott all of these banks
and all of these financial institutions?
(Applause)
You know, scientists, climate scientists,
some of them announced last week
and started doing this,
gluing themselves to the doors,
to the gates of these fossil
fuels facilities.
If climate scientists
have reached the conclusion
that more facts and more data
and more research is of absolutely no good
unless we, the people, can find the means
to break through the imprisonment
of our self-determination
on the part of large, massive polluters
who are just looking at profits,
then the scientists say
they have to go into the streets.
So I'm sorry to get all hot
and charged-up about this.
WPR: I think everyone appreciates it.
(Applause and cheers)
AG: But yes, what the IPCC report --
I mean, you know,
it's an asymptotic curve
that gets closer and closer
to absolute panic, OK?
And all the reports are very similar.
This is real.
You know, Voltaire once said,
if you can convince people of absurdities,
you can convince them
to commit atrocities.
We are seeing that in Ukraine today.
We are seeing that on a global basis
with this reckless indifference
to the future of humanity.
What will we say to the next generations
when they look back and see,
you had the chance to do this?
We have the means.
The International Energy Agency,
says that in order to cut emissions
by 50 percent in 2030,
we have all of the technologies we need,
fully developed, with deployment plans
that have been proven to work.
For the next 50 percent
between 2030 and 2050,
all of the technologies are in various
stages of development.
They can be ready if we decide
to develop them quickly enough,
they will be ready.
We have to stop destroying our future.
It sounds so simple,
but we have to break
through this paralysis.
WPR: Well, we have to break
Ladies and gentlemen, Al Gore.
AG: I have one other thing to say,
and I've said this before.
Do not give up hope.
And remember always,
that political will
is itself a renewable resource.
Thank you.
WPR: Thank you so much, Al.
(Applause and cheers)